how's it going bros my name is and today
we're going to play with a new app which
i freakin love it's a Chinese app where
you can make your Idol Isis a which
basically is an avatar so it scans your
face this beautiful face there we go
beautiful picture it's scanning scanning
scanning and now it creates our own
avatar hey prepare to have nightmares oh
[ __ ] yes let's pick a good outfit for
little Chinese Puetz oh my god what is
all this
oh pretty fat I look like my dad oh my
god
my Chinese father yeah I'm sure pretty
420 blasted am i right um how about this
yes I am beautiful oh oh my god yes
there it is
Casanova hello la la la
yes are you like yo don't I it's my
favorite sock kimono too tall one you
come
that's who talk so there you go lighter
your Wang oh my God we're talking I
wanted to try this on Edgar a lot of you
brother suggested I would try this with
my dog so we're gonna do that all right
and Garrett time to wake up
what the [ __ ] are you doing again look
into the camera oh my god it's gonna be
so hard okay I think we got it there
good job Edgar [ __ ] you [ __ ] ah you
look so stupid
okay I'm really curious how the [ __ ] is
gonna look like oh my god
what are they did to your face your
beautiful face
this price
you pay the fine
this is officially the greatest app ever
created let's try with Kermit the Frog
that'd be badass oh my god let's [ __ ] if
I Kermit yes ah I love it yes you
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god Matt yeah you
look so good oh wow
let's give her something good yeah she
would wear this oh my god it's my SIA
from frozen I would my girlfriend look
like with a beard let's find out my god
that is great alright we're doing one
where I'm [ __ ] with it and see you
see if we can create something good I
have seen hell oh oh oh yes oh yes that
shape of a [ __ ] head
take it
long
all right press if you enjoyed this
video leave a like click here for more
same type of videos and that's all you
need to know for now thank you both so
much for watching as always as a as in
bass oh my god how do you do that with a
nose I could never do that
my nose is too wide I can't do it